listen i'll give you one of these
capsules
you won't see daylight till tomorrow
okay the thc capitals oh these things
right here the strongest things in the
market what's in there
hash oil a little bit of oxygen and 100
milligrams of thc i got this new thing
if you want to sleep
you come see me what's in it anything
that puts you to sleep naturally
plus
100 milligrams
of either sativa
indica or hybrid marijuana whoa and you
drink it dog
two weeks ago i got so [ __ ] up because
i thought i was gonna go to new york and
die from the corolla
but i actually drank that [ __ ] i ate two
pills
nothing happened like i'm like [ __ ]
nothing's happened and then i drank the
[ __ ] liquid
and something started to happen but it
wasn't going fast enough it was like 10
15.
i wanted this i wanted to go to bed so i
popped two more oh
my god they all hit me at once like a
larry holmes
[ __ ] left hook
that night i woke up on the floor i fell
off the chair and the heater woke me up
i have a healer in my office
my back was on fire i woke up i'm like
why am i on fire here right i woke up
dug into the trance i went into the
kitchen i opened up the refrigerator and
i pulled out a half a pound of deluxe
boyhead cheese that she had just bought
and american cheese and i took a pack of
saltine crackers because in my mind i'm
not eating bread i'm okay
i'm not eating bread i'm ahead of this
[ __ ] eating crackers i ate the
whole half a pound that deluxe ham wow
and the whole thing of american cheese
and i just went to bed i woke up the
next morning i took off my mask it was a
big chunk of american cheese in the
sleep apnea didn't have
oh my god what the [ __ ] did i eat last
night
i [ __ ] went out my wife's like joey i
have a pound of ham i just bought that
what were you thinking i go what was i
thinking you have no idea what i was
going through last night you [ __ ] i
didn't get into bed for four in the
morning like i woke up
at 3 30 and was like what the [ __ ]
happened
you